after years of drinking Bud Light for
free Shane Gillis has finally signed a
partnership with his favorite beer after
their last spokesperson dropped the
balls I feel like you should be the new
spokesperson you can turn this
[__] around they better hurry up
and give me some money or I'm going to
start drinking cers like butl announced
that they are excited to be a part of
Shane gillis's 2024 tour but a lot of
fans online are also hoping this could
result in a Shane Gillis Super Bowl
commercial wa there's also been some
pretty hilarious articles written by
triggered authors who are calling Shane
homophobic and racist which is funny
because even when everyone was calling
Bud Light gay last year Shane kept
chugging along and now